hey guys Ryan right here hello there I'm
Veronica six toes that's right latina
chick on the channel uh-huh
going on I say that's racist and that's
racist Veronica why would you let me get
away with that how is that racist it
wasn't anything to do with Latinas yeah
whatever today we're gonna watch the
trailer the TV spot another one of
Godzilla have you seen any footage of
this I have not this is probably the
number one most anticipated movie I've
seen based off what subscribers
reactions are thank god you're hot
because that's what really counts really
I'm blushing but he says that about
everybody no I don't but she's really
hot I had the biggest crush on her when
I was like 15 men oh god it was so good
yeah we've known each other for like
what ten years ten years mate ten years
you've known each other ten years saying
ten years for like three years yeah and
still no luck no what is that say your
phone oops my cell phone turn your damn
phone off Veronica we're filming with
that ass hot [ __ ] so we're gonna watch
this TV spot 30 seconds of Awesomeness
they evacuated us so quickly
every have a picture
he's married to a lesbian you know I'm
gonna be gone oh she's cute that's one
of y'all's ancestors anaconda will
really not Panda the world nature has a
modem a power to restore mothers Wow
oh I wasn't expecting to see that it's
here the crap out of me I was like
that's really Godzilla right there he
got really excited - that was sweet
yeah I mean we're so fast that's a TV
spot Veronica you're a TV spot is no and
you're in the film business shame shame
TV spot is like whoa in the camera your
boobs look really good
why would you do that mom know I know my
name your mom's gonna watch us what's
going on six toes how you doing baby
yeah mr. six toes don't kill me don't
kill me mr. six to them imagine imagine
my dad scares the [ __ ] this video oh my
gosh what your dad looks in my eyes I
die a little bit I am so scared if he's
tough he's a tough [ __ ] he's
just he's just a boy inside maybe just
like you I'm not a boy but I have a
crush on you right like you are you can
roast down I just admitted my feelings
for you it's just not cute but yeah
that's pretty cool I mean the tones
resolved there I mean will I've said it
before a tone is like a really dark and
menacing and it seems like it's gonna
have great drama in it - yeah I was
immediately moved but yeah that's what I
like about it is that they're
advertising the characters they're not
so much advertising the monster itself
like you get bits and pieces in him but
it's more about the drama in conflict I
just remembering the moment that
Godzilla game dude that was [ __ ]
trivia but yeah thank you guys
recommending that called Nature has an
order if you're new to the channel
subscribe right here that was a button
there's a button right here yeah yeah
she's gonna be I'm hope speaking of
which we're gonna be putting together a
special 420 video so make sure to check
that out it's gonna be awesome
it'd be super cool it's gonna be super
cool dude we should probably get this
necklace I think that's what's making it
look like a like crazy cleavage do you
do it dude I've seen bikini photos of
her and yes oh my god I have started
them for so long
stop it mrs.six those
he knows not what he does yes I do he
knows exactly I know what I do every
night before I go to ok and this over no
no it's time to give some shoutouts
there's anyone who's not responsive to
my advances it's this girl she is always
like stop it well I don't know why
there's something inside me that just
wants to fight that which makes me want
to hit on you more so stop if you're not
gonna say yes to me one day then what is
the point of all this sexual tension
that I have created between myself and
you're not on that receiving and I'm
sorry subscriber shoutout time you are
such a good person i won because you're
so good to your subscribers in to your
fans that's really shy it's like super
super awesome now he's like famous and
he's like yo
6000 is awesome for a very long time and
now my awesomeness is finally being
recognized well thank you that was
really sweet was not expecting that but
thank you that's really kind of you know
it's really the subscribers that make
channel like pick nel 67 this dude's
dying for a shout-out every one every
other day he's on my ass about like dude
where's my [ __ ] shoutout really yeah
so here it is buddy Bicknell whatever
that means 67 is she be Bicknell 69 huh
huh 69 that was just a new pepper there
was a knee-slapper slap in the name hey
yo Jonathan Abreu
that's right oh damn you did a little
sled action shoutout to you my man
yeah are cool you're cool are you
Italian I'm half Italian Abrego
sounds Italian I guess the point I'm
trying to convey is you might be Italian
no seriously your boobs looking good I
know I should now I'm getting all
self-conscious know why I'm
complimenting you
Tata Surya said she loves me she loves
you
first subscriber that's a female to say
that they love me a lot of males have
told me that but I love you too thank
you you I will never forget you and one
day we will meet and it will be awesome
and she will be jealous you will be you
watch I'm gonna meet him with her in
front of you I want you to be there and
it's just so glad I can't
mind I'm expressing exactly what's on my
mind cuz they would just be not stop sex
that's what it is